Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 24th,
2012 and as you can see,
the way I stress December 24th that I am,
I am,
I am letting you guys know that I
realize that it's Christmas Eve.
Okay.
I realized that therefore this
has to be a very special podcast,
uh, which it won't be, but I'm
just letting you know that.
I know that you feel that
it should be special.
I had some sort of Christmas special going
on here singing you guys some holiday
tunes
have all the jolly Christmas.
Oh,
it's the best time of the year.
Everybody is pretty cool except
for that douchey sister married.
There's always one, right? There's
always going to be that one fucking guy.
Everybody's having a good time. And then
this one has to come in, moping around,
you know,
who was it?
The chick with the substance
abuse problem or the Moody Guy.
I'd rather have the substance abuse chick
around in the Moody Guy, Moody guys.
The worst he comes in, right? Like
the fucking antithesis of mistletoe.
You know,
he should have mistletoe on his
shoes pointed the other direction,
like some sort of devil reference,
you know,
instead of hanging from the heavens
is coming up from the fucking fool,
right?
Kiss my fucking feed everybody cause
you're gonna have to deal with me and my
mood because I'm not just going to
have the decency to be miserable,
miserable over in the corner.
I'm going to fucking sit down right in
front of everybody and just sit there
sulking,
you know,
and there'll be a couple
of fucking hardcore people
who will see it and they'll
just roll their eyes.
But there's always the one Douche,
the one chick who's a member of the four
h club or whatever the hell it is that
she does. Bake sales helps
out with the church car wash,
whatever the fuck she does,
but she know she has to f with manner,
with manner. You look sad. Oh my God,
he sees,
she sees fucking sad every year.
Watch the language around the mistletoe.
Karen,
don't fucking do this.
Don't every fucking year.
I don't care if their kids
are going to hear right.
Anyway, they got a hair, right.
Anyway,
all right.
Every year this douche comes in looking
like fucking droopy dog and I'm sick of
it. It's not my fault. His lights,
I don't care if he could hear me
quartzy sleeping because he's leaving.
You're leaving, you'll leave all,
where are you going to go kill
yourself in the fucking rest area?
Right? It's one of those deals
every year. There's that Douche.
Then there's always the dose you as to
try and top everybody's stories. You know,
you could be sitting there with
the fucking astronaut each,
some out,
try to top or correct them.
Well, actually I thought, uh,
according to, uh, you know what?
I don't know what video
games, some fucking astronaut
video game to dose played.
He'd actually try to question a real
artist who even knows a national at this
point,
aren't they all dead?
Did the people who are on the space
shuttle where they considered astronauts?
Cause I didn't consider them astronauts.
You're not an astronaut if
you're in a plane. Okay.
And I know it's a big one and I know
it's got rockets on it initially.
All right?
But all I know is that the astronauts
that I grew up on with what fucking day.
We're at the top of a missile.
That's what day did you didn't
steer that fucking thing?
I mean how they got back,
they had a little capsule then
he's just lean to one side.
You kept rolling back towards the
earth. Hope when you'd reenter, right.
Then the parachutes came out and they
couldn't fucking find you cause all we had
was binoculars. You know,
where is he? I don't see them.
Okay.
All right. Hang on. The Star Bar,
not, not, not the star board.
Right. And you're fucking sitting there
in the water, clinging to a sting ray.
If you lucky, you landed on an
island and then you met a genie.
Okay.
Who called your master.
But for some reason you never fucked her.
But other than that, that's
what an astronaut was. Even
flying a fucking plane,
you know, Wheaton Spaghettios, whatever
the fuck they did, and then land,
he get towed to the gate by a
fucking Toyota Tundra. All right.
That's not an astronaut.
To me,
that's a very impressive pilot.
Very impressed.
You went a lot higher than the jumbo jet.
I flew to Syracuse.
Sin Hat's off to you sir.
Um, I just heard Johnny
Mathis in the car, in the car.
Fucking guy's great. You know
what the hell song was he singing?
Yeah.
What the fuck song was he saying?
It's something about a,
it's the top 10 in your
heart that though. Oh, Bo.
Ah, fuck. How does it go fast?
I do buddy.
But then you pop it down
buckets right there. Something
about Deb, what the jingle.
Linea is a song in your
heart and I've got skis.
You want me to get Johnny Mathis always
picture that Christmas album when he was
sitting there with his, you know
his skis and sweater on, you know
a fuck though.
You know,
you think if you going to bring up a
fucking something you just heard you could
remember it, wouldn't ya
ward your, um, anyways,
I hope you guys have a very merry
Christmas. It is one day away.
Have you finished your shopping? I know
the podcast is late. I know. It's like,
you know what,
I actually recorded it this morning and
I was fucking with my dog on it and he
unplugged my device and
then some it all got erased.
So this is the second time I'm doing it.
So I think because of that,
I think I saw pretty jolly
right about now don't you
still coughing up mold?
Any doctors listened to this podcast?
Do you? Oh that's, that's a, I
don't know if that's impressive.
Why would you listen to this podcast?
Do you need a break from thinking?
Cause you're so fucking smart cause you
went to college until you were 35 and
now you're fucking 900 grand in debt
and you're looking up people's assholes.
Really that was your game plan.
Okay.
You know, if you wanted to fuck a nurse,
you, you could have just had your girl,
you know, just put on a nurse's
outfit. What's the difference?
The goods are all the same. Did you
really need to go through all of that?
Just so you could walk around instead of
somebody saying, you know Mr. Johnson,
they have to be like Dr. Johnson.
I don't like how doctors,
like when they go to a fucking
restaurant, they have to say, you know,
table four and they've got
to be, you know, fucking,
you know, doctor Marblehead.
Okay.
Why can't you say just say four from
Marblehead? What I picked Marblehead.
I don't know why Peterson,
you know, for, for Peterson,
it's got four for Dr. Peterson.
You know,
get over yourself. You fucking
Douche. So many of those,
the goddamn doctors do,
are not involved in life and death shit.
I'm not saying they don't kill people
and I'm not, I guess. Well, you know,
if they fuck up, they can kill
somebody. But a lot of them, you know,
they're looking at toes,
they look checking out your ears,
your throat and that type of shit.
You know that those are,
they like the Jiffy Lube doctors,
you know, that's all they're doin.
Change in a fucking air filter, draining
out the oil, put the blood back in,
put a new filter on, pour the shit
back in the top of the engine.
Call me in two days. That's
all you're doing. All right.
Okay.
Those real guys that deal
with the fucking, the insides,
the Pistons and all that Shit.
Those are the guys
you know. Oh, the computer.
Those are the real doctors,
you know?
So next time you go out to a fucking,
whatever the fuck it's called,
cracker barrel. Just say
your last name. Alright.
Dr. Peterson.
You fucking do show getting mugged.
You know,
going to, what would it
go to? Fucking restaurant.
Sit to stand up comedian
per table for one.
Cause I'm on the road and I'm lonely.
Comedian,
burr immediate bar table for one.
Anyways,
did you guys watch any football?
Now it gives a fuck about football.
It's almost over. Can you believe how
fucking fast the NFL season goes by?
Why is it so short? You know why?
Because it's a fucking man's game.
That's why September,
October, November, December.
And you're into playoffs for months.
Baseball starts in April.
So that's April, May, June,
July. You just be right now.
We would be in the dog days of summer
with baseball, but football, it's fucking,
it's almost over.
You know,
this time next month we'll be
sitting there waiting for the, uh,
the pro bowl, which I'm
going to, by the way,
I'm going to be out there with like
87 other people in that stadium.
It, it's fucking, uh,
do you realize this is how much of
a pussy game baseball is or mas?
Let's spin it positively because
it's Christmas Eve. It's the e for,
for Christmas.
MMM.
This is how manly football is.
Baseball players,
if you're healthy for the whole year,
you play as many professional games as
a football player plays in a 10 year
career, you know, and
after a 10 year career,
most football players, they have damaged
that they're not walking away from,
they got some sort of a limp,
some sort of twitch in their eye.
They got voices in their head,
their head doesn't fucking turn anymore.
They got something their knees blown out.
They got something. Baseball players,
what do they got?
Huh?
Other than a broad and every fucking
other city had never want to go to,
you know, they got chicks
in Baltimore, Kansas City,
Elizabeth's NFL cities. Let me think of
a fucked up. Wait, there's this 32 teams.
There's more football teams and
baseball that doesn't work out, does it?
Whatever. I'm just, I'm
just upset. Why is it,
why didn't he just goes by
so fucking fast. Anyways,
I tell you something.
I got to tell you something right now.
I think Peyton manning has a good shot
at tying his younger brother with the
ring this year. What do you think
about that? Earlier this year,
you know I was like the
giants or the fucking giants.
You don't need to tell a patriots fan
about the giants. Ah, you don't need it
all right.
I kept waiting for them to turn it on
versus he was freaking out in November.
I'm like, dude, they do this every year.
They pace themselves and then they start
trying right around fucking about a
week before Thanksgiving and then they
just go on a run and they just punch
everybody in the mouth.
Eli closes his eyes,
looks at the opposite end zone and throws
the ball instead sticks to somebody's
helmet or fucking drops in
out of the heavens, in double,
in the expression on his
face. Never changes. You know,
he's like the Manchurian candidate,
a fucking NFL players.
MMM.
Never seen a quarterback
is good as him as look,
as stupid as he does with a helmet on.
It's like,
I don't think I would look worse
with the helmet on. You know,
usually someone who's not athletic like
myself when we put on athletic equipment,
it's just funny. We don't look
cool. We look like idiots. And uh,
as good as Eli is, he,
he looks like a guy.
He looks like the last guy you
would pick in gym class. Anyways,
I'm just pissed because he beat us every
time we go to the fucking super bowl.
MMM.
But anyways,
the giants are out.
Yeah.
Now the 40 niners I don't,
I dunno what to think about them.
After that drubbing last night against
Seattle and I was really rooting for the
40 niners I've always liked the 49 as
well. That's not true. In 81 I didn't,
I was a cowboys fan and, uh, but I,
I just, you know, by the end of it,
I just, you know, the West Coast
Offense, Bill Walsh, I'll let shit,
I just loved them.
MMM.
And you know, Pete Carroll drives
me nuts. I can't stand that guy.
I don't like that guy because he
looks like the greatest guy ever.
He looks like he just rescued
a cat out of a tree, you know,
after rescue a dog from a shelter
after a, you know, I don't know,
saving somebody from drowning. He just
looked the key looks like a fucking do.
It looks like a Mormon, you know? Could
you look any more wholesome than that guy?
He looks, he goes to church every
week and sings hymns, you know,
only has sex missionary style, you
know, only does it for procreation.
You know what I mean? Like there's
nothing fucking wrong with the guy yet.
The way he left fucking, uh, USC.
I mean, John Calipari
must've been like Nice, nice.
The way it's done that,
that's how I get that. Right.
You see what he just did that size?
That's how it's done.
Okay?
It's how it's done. You break every
fucking rule. You fucking can.
You win championships
and right when you smell,
those mother fuckers come and you leave
and you let the school deal with it.
Right? That's what the
fuck he did. You know?
So then he's up there
looking all wholesome.
And the worst thing about
losing to a Pete Carroll team,
or just whenever a Pete Carroll
team scores a touchdown,
is they're always going to cut to that
wholesome guy and you're going to catch
him reacting to the touchdown.
And what does he do?
Does he make like a fucking war face?
Does he go,
fuck you like Rex Ryan
something manly? No. He goes, oh
woo.
It's genius. It's fucking g.
It's the what you expected. Like,
and fuck. Yeah, he's back. They're
going to do that. You don't expect to,
somebody be like,
whoo,
but skip down the fucking sidelines.
It makes it even more annoying.
Okay.
To lose to somebody if somebody is like
fucking brow and like a grizzly bear.
Yeah. It makes it losing a little
more acceptable. But when that,
when they're making noises, you'd make a
few are pushing your toddler on a swing.
It's a, it's really degraded.
So anyways, you know,
Seattle just in general, it's just fucking
annoying. It's a great goddamn city.
But I don't like this stadium,
how they designed it.
So there are fans that aren't, that loud
would sound louder. I don't like that.
And then they get all this credit,
right?
Well these fans is so loud.
No, the architect was awesome.
Um, anyways, so now I'm
looking, I don't know.
Yeah,
I think Green Bay still fucking in it.
I have no idea.
Now all of a sudden it seems up for grabs.
After the last couple of years,
I was looking at the NFC going, this
is completely lopsided. You know,
the three top teams in the
league are in the NFC, so you're,
you're going to be watching the Superbowl
in the NFC championship game at the
very least. And uh, the AFC,
we're just going to show up to get
our fucking asses kicked. You know,
that's just been my, my opinion. Okay.
And I stand by my criticism of my own
teams. Fucking defense. As you saw,
we struggled with the Goddamn Jaguars.
All right? And I know, you know,
Brady threw a couple of pics
in that type of thing, but bay,
but that we made their quarterback,
whatever the fucking Dick, Chad Henne,
whatever the hell his name is,
you know,
[inaudible] made that guy
looked like John Elway.
So anyways, I got to fill in a and any
kind of fill in the Peyton manning though.
He's gotta you gotta fucking Shit.
He's got a chance.
And I'm somehow rooting for the guy.
I'm trying to hold up my hatred
of the guy. And I did too.
I just don't have it anymore. Once he
left the colts, it just, it's just,
he's not on the colts anymore. I
don't care. And now he's an old guy.
I'm an old guy. How do I not root for
an old guy? He's so fucking old guy.
I can relate. I can relate to it. Um,
I got tightened my stupid password
here. Do you guys know, uh, here's,
here's something that
happened yesterday during, uh,
the Patriots game that
I was watching this,
this is how much the game has changed.
Wes,
welcome the great Wes Welker
going to be in the very least,
we'll be in the New England
Patriots Hall of fame. All right.
He's got to stay healthy. He
needs a couple. Yeah, but good.
Probably about 4,000 more yards and he's
going to be in the pro football hall of
fame, right? So I love the guy, you know,
speedy white guy playing wide
receiver. It gives, it gives, you know,
uncoordinated white dudes like me.
Hope gives us a role model,
you know what I mean? Um, so anyways,
he catches a ball and they go,
Wes Welker just broke Jerry Rice's record
and immediately my fucking ears perk
up going a Wes Welker
broke a Jerry Rice record.
What record did he break?
He broke the record for the most games.
10 or more catches in a game with his
18th game of having 10 or more catches.
And I was like,
Wes Welker caught 10 or more
passes more in his career.
Then Jerry Rice. You know what? I think
I have to go to the pope pro football,
reference.com the best football
website out there. By the way,
stay away from ESPN and the NFL one,
they're too fucking busy selling
their channel and their league.
This is just no bullshit.
Trim the fucking fat.
So Wes Welker holds the record for
the most games as a wide receiver,
catching 10 or more
passes his career yards,
8,486 and he is played one two three four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine seasons and nine seasons.
He did what Jerry Rice did
in 20 seasons and Jerry Rice,
his career total for yards is 22,895
that's how the game's changed.
These little fucking passes, which would
have been handoffs back in the day.
These guys that they're
and their fucking statue,
there's gotta be an asterisk next to
that one. Here's the average yards.
Wes Welker has 15 yards his first year,
10.3 10.5 10.5 11.0 9.9
that's for the year.
That's was his average per catch.
9.9 yards.
12.9 11.5 here's Jerry Rice.
All right,
where the fuck are we?
18 point 918.3 16.6 20.4
18.1 you get the point,
right?
Yeah.
Back in the day,
they fucking,
they sled that fucking pig scan around
the god Damn Day doing this little,
oh, here you go. Shit. I throw,
I throw fucking nine yard passes to my
three year old fucking Wes Welker has to
God damn record for that Bull Shit.
Fucking nine yard cray. Hell, I'll catch
buckshot nine yards away. That ain't shit
sort of saying all these fucking
records are getting broken out. Dan.
All a Dan Marino's records or fall it.
Dan Marino stood in the fucking pocket.
You throw the ball in,
sitting there throwing these
little bitch ass passes down.
You know there's gotta be sure they
got it. It has to be a new stat.
Okay? There's gotta be a new
stat where a handoff to handoff.
And if you throw the fucking
ball, it's got to, it's,
it's gotta be at least 10 fucking yards.
How about that?
We say that, can we create a new
name for whatever the fuck it is?
When a quarterback drops back to pass
and throws a three yard pass to somebody,
it does that 35 times a game.
Hey,
Jess [inaudible] starts record
for above completions in a row.
Hey Jess,
through 26 six yard passes in a row.
Well, I gotta tell you
frank one a, you do the,
you get put in the same
sentence as Bart Starr luck.
You know you've accomplished something.
Um, I dunno. I'm just a crabby
old man. Don't listen to me.
I'm just fucking saying. That's all
I'm saying. Give me a fucking break.
Wes Welker did something and nine season,
it took Jerry Rice.
20 seasons to do and you're going to
tell me there's something right about the
league. There's something right about
that. Well, maybe in your world, sir,
and maybe in your universe, ma'am, but
not mine. When you think about that?
Well maybe I don't give a shit
when you think about that.
You ever think about that? Huh? There's
a lot to think about Matt. All right,
let's do a commercial here.
stamps.com everybody with
the holidays almost here.
Literally almost here. You don't
have time to go to the post office.
What do they mean? But the holidays almost
here. Christmas. What about Kwanzaa?
Hanukkah, you know, have
those common gone already?
I Dunno. Let's stick to the copy
here. What the holidays almost here.
Granted they gave me this three weeks ago.
You don't have time to go to the
post office. Traffic, parking,
obese people.
Um,
it will be packed with everyone
mailing holiday gifts and packages. So,
so do what I do. Jesus. This is the
worst read ever. So do what I do.
Use stamps.com instead, cause God
knows I'm too stupid to read out loud.
So thank God they came up
with this wonderful system.
What is his stance? Dotcom?
You ask with stamps.com you can avoid the,
all the hassle of going to the post
office during the busy holiday season.
Everything you would do with the post
office, you can do right from your desk.
Buy and print official US postage
using your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or package.
The instant you need it,
then the mailman picks it up. That's it.
That's all it is. So easy. So convenient.
What else do you need? They're doing
everything but bringing you a sandwich.
I use stamps.com to send out all
my DVDs for all my road gigs.
I absolutely love it. Um, you should get,
you should try to actually got to get
a new scale. I've used it so much,
I broke it. Well actually I
something on it the other day,
so I gotta I gotta get a new
scale. Um, special offer right now.
Get this special offer when
you use my last name, burp.
But you are our for a no
risk trial plus $110 bonus.
That includes a digital scale that I
just broke and up to $55 free postage.
They given you 55 bucks during the holiday
season. Come on. What more do you want?
Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in [inaudible],
B u r r that stamps.com enter birth.
All right.
Oh, this mold, this mold
won't leave me alone.
So I um,
I know what you're thinking.
We'll build next time you
go to a restaurant rather
than being insecure about
the doctor,
the Doctor Party of four,
why don't you fucking wattle up to
them and ask them about, you know,
is it okay to smoke a moldy cigar
once in your life every day?
The guy at the cigar told me, he
said, he said I'd be fine. You know,
that's how a guy goes to the doctor.
He talks to some guy,
he doesn't know who isn't a doctor,
vaguely describes what he did and goes,
you think I'll be all right. And you
know the guy goes and you're like,
all right and then you girl gets on you.
Why don't you go to the doctor?
Cause I talked to that
fucking guy over there,
that guy I am taking out the trash.
Hey Sweetheart,
you don't make fun of what a guy does for
a living. Okay? It's an unwritten rule.
It's an unwritten rule.
Now you look at down to the ground as
we walked back to the car and you don't
say good night to nobody. Pope
of Greenwich Village. Thank you.
And I avoided the not having a
fun part. Um, all right. So what,
what went on in the world this week?
I had an awesome week.
I did another episode of
Glee Nudge, Nudge, wink,
wink, and could not have had more fun.
I will let you know when it comes out.
Um,
and that was my last work for this
year and I ain't doing shit baby.
I ain't doing anything. I recorded the
podcast earlier today and like I said,
I was fucking with my dog
and, uh, during the podcast,
wrestling with her and stuff,
it was funny as hell,
but we got a little too rough and
an unplugged my thing here and, uh,
the recording and I
lost that podcast and I,
I'm still, I still think about
it sometimes not. So anyways,
I had to make a fucking pie today.
Made an apple pie and a,
there was a little collateral
damage with the crust on top.
Made it from scratch pitches.
Okay.
Till I know I come off like
I'm miserable and I'm cynical,
but I like Johnny Mathis, Christmas
music and I can make a pie from scratch.
You know, what are you doing today? I
don't want to get old John Lennon on you.
And so this is Chris Moses.
Then what have you
done? Um, I got it down.
The big fucking thing about making a pie,
a pie crust,
you can't be intimidated by the flower.
That's the thing.
I finally realized I was approaching it
like a bitch every year. I was like, Woo,
Woo, Woo woo man. And I'd fuck
it up this year I was like,
I don't give a fuck. I got a
whole bag of flour, you know,
like a pimp that has a whole stable
of horse just sitting there like,
all right lady,
you either make this fucking work or
I'll get another one in there and replace
you. That was the thing. So I'm out in
the kitchen. Right. And when you bake,
you know, aside from, you know, risking
getting gay bashed in your own kitchen,
when you bake as a male,
you gotta give you gotta put an apron on
because your hands are going to get all
sticky. So, uh, believe it
or not, I don't own an apron.
And the only apron in the house
is the one my mother got for Nia.
And I swear to God, it's like this floral
pattern pattern, frilly fucking thing.
Like if an old lady had it
on, you'd be like, oh my God,
that's the greatest grandmother ever. So
I got this fucking thing on, you know,
Nias and the fucking living room.
So I'm in the kitchen,
I got the door closed and she knows I'm
making a pie and she starts to smell the
Philly. And, uh,
I do that food network shit where I
don't measure this shit out. As I,
as I, you know, as I'm making
it, you know, I have it,
I measured the shit out and I put it all
in these little fucking things so I can
just Bam, Bam, Bam, like I'm on a
shelf. You know, he put the cream in,
then you had the sugar with sat together.
Now a little bit of salt,
little bit of Nutmeg, little cinnamon,
you know, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam.
And the whole fucking thing goes,
whatever your hands get all fucking
stick soap sitting there, right?
And appealing the apples
and that type of shit.
And I go to pick up one and it fucking
the apple falls and it lands on two of my
little things that already have measured
out. And they tip over on the counter.
And then the apple fucking lands on
the floor and roles across the kitchen.
[inaudible] now,
Nia always gets on me for my temper,
flipping out and causing intention.
And I realized that, okay.
So when I flipped out,
rather than screaming,
I sort of crouch down.
Okay.
And I just went,
wow.
Something like that.
It was with his fucking apron on.
So Nia heard that, you
know, she, it wasn't loud,
but the intensity was fucking ridiculous.
So she comes bursting in to make
sure I'm all right. And she's like,
she's like Billy, you okay? And I
came in and got, yeah, yeah, I'm fine.
And then she sees me standing in that
apron. It might've been the hardest.
I think I ever heard her laugh.
I knew I'd look a little stupid,
but like she almost fucking passed out.
She like laughed I think
for five minutes straight.
And every time she started the stop she
started going to get, you know, get,
someone's laughing so hard, you start
laughing. It was one of those deals.
And I'm sitting there trying to peel
the apples and she's laughing so hard.
I got like fucking tears in my eyes and
I can't, I can't see what I'm doing. Um,
but long story short,
long story short,
I just remeasured the shit lost a
little nutmeg or whatever and um,
I cooked it, had little collateral damage
with the fucking doe on the, uh, the,
the one on top and I got to tell you,
it's nice.
It's a good look and fucking
pie to the point I'm going,
I'm going to post it and I'll tell
you as far as looks, I give it a six.
I'd give it a six.
Now I know once it gets posted to the
internet and all you miserable cons who
aren't happy with your lives, whether
it be like being like, you know what?
That's not too bad. That's not too
bad a job. I know you guys are good.
You're going to fucking, you know,
you're going to tear it to shreds.
You know when I say I say God bless you.
I say happy holidays to you too.
I'm sorry that your life,
I'm sorry you didn't get that fire
engine under the Christmas tree.
And rather than looking at your
parents or your girlfriend,
whatever the fuck you, God, we
didn't get you to that fire engine.
You're going to decide to take it
out on me and my innocent little pie.
All right. Hope you feel
good about yourself. Um,
what else? What else are we going to talk
about? Oh, I know a buddy of mine, uh,
you know,
the one who was questioning my loyalty
to the Patriots Cause I had the audacity
to say that their defense stinks.
Uh,
actually he called me after
the Jaguar's game and said,
I think I agree with you now.
Um,
and then he also, he left a message,
he asked me if I saw the, uh,
the NRA press conference,
you know, or as he said,
the Ana Dogc the fucking Nra,
uh, press conference, fuck,
where's this mold going
to be out of my system
according to the guy at the
cigar store will be fine. Um,
as he sells me another cigar,
I'm, what the hell was I
talking about? Yeah. So yeah.
He said, dude, you gotta check out the
Santa Ira thing. And he goes, it's like,
and he said to me, he goes,
and, you know, make dope. I'm,
I'm in the middle and I know a million
people who say I'm in the middle and
they're not in the middle. I've said,
I'm in the middle. I'm not in the middle.
I leaned to the left with a nice
fucking upper cutter. Right.
That's where I am.
You know,
I am to the left when it comes to the
work and mad when it comes to the twinkle
toes when it comes to,
you know,
people wanting to come to the country,
I'm to the left,
you know when it comes to other shit,
like taking responsibility for your
fucking actions. I'm on the right.
No it isn't. Okay, you're
a Douche. Go Fuck Yourself.
Go make it right or go sit in
that Shell and pay your dues.
You don't get a do over all the pens,
but I mainly, mainly on the right,
I'm one of the angriest liberals.
You'll ever fucking me.
I guess I'm supposed to be
doing yoga or something. I miss,
I missed something out in on the,
on the pamphlet or what?
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but this guy, you know, I got to,
I got a bunch of people like versus
another guy. He's one of them. Those guys,
the classic guy who says he's in the
middle. You're like, dude, you're not.
You lean this way. You
totally, every fucking issue I
bring up. You lean this way.
And then they always say the same thing.
It's the dumbest thing ever going
to fuck with your registered.
That's a classic thing.
You,
you registered independent and then argue
all one side and then when people just
accuse you, yeah, yeah, you're
fucking liberal. You're a
conservative. And they go,
I'm a registered independent. Well,
you didn't have to pass a test.
You know,
you just,
you just defined yourself
as an independent.
The same way Madison Square Garden
just gives itself the nickname,
the world's most famous arena,
you know,
and then everybody just does. It's
the world's most, there it is.
There's the world's most famous arena,
a cookie cutter fucking stadium,
a stadium. That one arena that
was made during the worst,
most uncreative time of arenas,
the world's most famous arena.
If you can tell me how that thing looks
more different than any other stadium
during that fucking time that God damn it,
I'll make you an apple pie.
What do you feel about
that? Um, so anyways,
he goes, uh, yes.
All you people out there who
think just because you're a,
you're a registered independent and then
therefore you can just argue the same
side of every fucking argument and still,
you know,
and then that's your parachute.
I'm a registered independent. Hey,
buy my best friend's black. You
know, it's like one of those deals.
It's your little get out of jail
fucking bullshit thing. All right,
I'm here to tell you you're not fooling
anybody. Alright, you're full of shit.
But this guy,
he actually,
I've known him for 20 years and I really
don't know how he feels about anything.
It keeps the shit real
close to the vest. And, uh,
he always surprises me every time I
think he's going this way. Go that way.
I mean, I don't know. He might be a
contrarian. I have no fucking idea.
You might just be arguing the opposite
side just to fucking drive me nuts.
But anyways, he says, check out
this NRA thing. He goes, uh,
he was, you know, I don't really feel
one way or the another about it, but, uh,
these guys come off like it's a
fucking cartoon. Like their solution.
Yeah.
To The gun situation is more guns.
That's what he tells me.
So I sit down and I go,
I got to fucking watch this shit.
Get some material out
of this. Right. Yeah.
And,
uh,
I put it on and I watched
it and I got to admit,
I thought the guy made a lot
of good points. I don't often,
we get hate mail over this.
I don't,
I don't mean I don't have a
problem if they ban, you know,
semiotic semiautomatic,
a fucking assault weapons,
I don't know what you
need one of those four,
you know,
if you using it to hunt you fucking
cheating. Like how bad a shot of you did.
You got to bang, Bang, Bang,
Bang, Bang. That they got it.
I got it. I got it. Sorry.
Sorry.
I got it.
Got It.
You know,
so I don't have a problem with that,
but like,
I don't like the whole demonizing of
people who own guns that you're just
automatically evil. It's stupid.
That'd be like demonizing me.
I use a computer. So
therefore, uh, you know,
I advocate,
uh,
sexual predators or people who steal
your identity. You know what I mean?
I mean, I, I kind of think
if you're in the NRA,
you got your gun legally and I think I,
I vote with no status whatsoever.
Completely over my head. No research,
no nothing. I'm willing to bet.
Okay.
All right. Uh, Marangu Pie. It's
all gonna be pies this week,
Dan, I would say like night, what? 99%
of the people who register a gun legally,
first of all,
probably never do anything.
Most of them probably
never do anything more.
Then go down to the fucking
gun range and shoot it.
Then he got another percentage
that actually go out and
they go shoot a pheasant
or quail or an elk or some
bullshit like that. Right.
But the amount that actually go out and
commit a fucking crime or shoot somebody
as somebody, I wouldn't,
you know the problem,
you know what the fucking problem is,
is we don't have a way of
weeding out sociopath's
Psychos, maniacs. There's
no way to find them.
That's what you need to do.
If you could do that,
if you could some how fucking do that.
You wouldn't even need metal
detectors at the airport.
You wouldn't need anything. There
could be a gun in every fucking house.
No one's ever going to go
out and deliberately do
something. Somebody's gonna,
you know, obviously have an accident,
but shit, you have accidents in cars.
People put pools in their backyard,
people will fucking break their necks.
Shit happens. People fall
off ladders. Shit fucking
happen. There's gotta be a way,
you know,
I was running shit. I will, you know,
when you're like on a fucking tangent,
you realize halfway through how dumb
you sound. That was just a moment,
right there was like,
if was running shit
yet, you listen because you laughing
at me. Huh? You I go fuck yourself.
I don't care if I'm feeling good.
I made a pie today.
And what have you done?
Um,
if I was running shit,
I would go to the people who came up
with that black light that may helps you
find Jizan and a quilt,
you know, and be like,
make one of those lights for Psychos,
you know?
And then I would replace all the lights
in, in the street lights. You know,
with that light,
which would create jobs.
Yeah.
You know, and then with the surplus
of that money, we'd have healthcare.
Uh, just stay with me on this one
and it'll be like this maniac light.
Okay.
And if you're a good shit,
you have a soul and you have a
fucking hat and you're not a cunt.
It would be this one particular color.
See, nobody would know about this shit.
We all top secret it just be,
I know about it.
The guys who invented it and all the
million people who have had an unscrew the
old light bulbs and put no,
you don't have to tell them.
Just tell them it's some
new energy efficient thing.
He just weed out all the psychosis and
I know what all the liberals are gonna
say and they'll let you deal with them.
Do you kill them if you kill all the,
you're just VAD as laugh.
Okay.
All right, well then I'll go
classic right wing. We take them,
we stick them on a fucking island.
Okay.
Let them all kill each other.
Now that would be a dumb thing then.
That would be stupid. That would be a
dumb fucking liberal way of doing things.
But we can't kill these people.
We can't illegally detain them because
they haven't done anything yet.
Fat.
Yeah.
And then you stick them on an
island and then you create this.
Can you dig it?
Fucking island,
you know,
God help us when those cons get organized
and I'll come back a shore. All right.
Isn't that enough? Will Smith's Tom
Cruise's and fucking then I what not.
Give me another action here with Chuck
Norris is out there to stop that level
evil.
That's the thing you got to um,
okay.
Like those fucking people holding up
signs saying that the NRA is killing
children. Um, is is just, first of all,
they weaken that side of the argument
because they're coming off like complete
psychopaths.
You know,
I don't know.
I find the press really annoying to like,
they had already made up their minds.
Like they were all over taking pictures
of the people holding up the protesting
things and some, one of the press
guys, I'm assuming suppress guy,
I don't know who it was, but
he's in the room, you know,
so meaning it's gotta be somebody from
the press yells at the NRA guy and he
goes, uh, what do you
think about the protesters?
And the NRA guy doesn't say anything,
just continues with his speech.
And then the same in the
crowd goes, uh, and he goes,
he goes off the stick with
the script. It's like, dude,
are you,
are you still a reporter at that point?
Because you don't sound like when your
job is to go down there and report what
happened. I'm fine with what do
you think about the protesters?
Even then that was borderline because
the guy was still in the middle of a
statement. But, but that's
okay because it did happen.
But when the guy chooses no comment,
that's what you report. No comment.
He goes on to have clause,
stick with the script.
I Dunno. That's a fucking
idiot Smith. It did just, I,
I don't, that there is no
fucking solution until,
until you can come up with something.
As much as I was making a joke about
having a cycle streetlight that identifies
maniacs, until you do
that, I don't give a fuck.
You know,
there's still gonna be keep going
to be problems. Isn't there?
Jesus Christ with those fucking
maniacs do in the Middle East.
They don't even use guns.
They got out of the home depot.
They get a fucking thing of fertilizer,
right.
Whatever the fuck they do when they walk
into a food court, blow themselves up.
Now what are they going to do close
down the hardware stores. All right,
I'm going to hold my head.
Uh,
so this is Christmas.
All Right,
this is cruising along 43 minutes in.
Hey everybody,
did you enjoy the podcast this year as
much as I did? Well, I sure hope you did.
Um, oh, they also blame video games,
blaming video games, which um, I dunno.
I don't know what to tell you.
I find violent video games
to be a stress relieving.
I also find going to a gun range and
shooting a gun to be oddly calming,
the same sort of calm I get
when I make a fucking apple pie.
I'm not even lying to you. I, I
get that same level of enjoyment
because I'm not a psycho. I'm
a cut. I'm a dick. I'm a moron,
but I'm not a psycho.
All right,
I'll stand you come up with that light.
I'll fucking stand underneath it all.
You're going to see you as a bald
spot in a, in a, in a beautiful soul.
Alright, plowing ahead here
by the way, people, I got to,
I got a couple of gigs coming up in 2013.
Um,
in January I'm going to be at slappers
flappers comedy club in Burbank,
California. Absolutely
love this club. And uh,
I'm hoping to have a couple of a
up and coming heavy hitters open.
And for me, I haven't reached
out to anybody yet, but um,
flappers in Burbank and uh,
that's going to be on January
10th two shows. We'll put,
we'll give you the links and everything.
If you go to the podcast page on bill
bird.com and then on November 26th,
I am going to be out in Honolulu,
Hawaii at the uh,
hooky Lao fucking,
what the fuck is the name of the God damn
thing? Sam The worst. See why, why do I,
why do I talk myself into
these damn corners? Oh, cause
you're not organized bill.
You know,
you don't have any sort of,
you know setlist is oh fuck yourself.
Um Oh, I thought it was gonna be up
on my website. Where the fuck is it?
Whatever. Just look, you do the work.
Look up bill burr and fucking
to why and you'll see it.
It's January 26th I will be there and uh,
and I'm going to the pro bowl.
He won't be able to miss me.
It'd be me and fucking 83 other
people in Hawaiian shirts.
It's going to be awesome. And then
I'm at the Wilbur Theater, Boston,
Massachusetts.
My old stomping grounds where I started
Wilbur theater right across some Nick's
comedy stop where I started March 2nd,
1992 on an open mic night, long,
long time ago. Uh, Wilbur theater.
February 21st two shows
and February 22nd one show.
And other than that,
the only other thing I have that's on
sale right now is May 30th in Baltimore,
Maryland.
And I'm at the Mary Hoff Symphony Hall.
Doesn't that sound amazing?
You know a lot. I'm going
to be, it's a symphony hall.
I'll sound like a fucking Seahawk fan.
It's all that artificial help. Um,
all right,
back to the podcast here.
So let's answer some questions
here. Um, if you'd like to email me,
it's uh, oh, what the fuck is it?
I think it's built the MM podcast.com
we'll have that link up there too.
I haven't said it so long. I forget
what the fuck it is. Um, all right.
It's terrible. Whatever you guys want
to be working today, are you, you know,
once you're home putting on a sweater,
a questions from New Zealand. So, you
know what's great about New Zealand?
I was at a Christmas party last night
and I met some woman there and uh,
she was saying how in World War One
that when Great Britain declared war on
Germany, that New Zealand felt,
because they were their colony,
both of them in Australia,
they had to follow suit.
So they told England that, Yay,
we're right there with you.
And you know what England did?
Did they mix them in with their troops?
Now you will see that all quiet on the
western front, that trench warfare,
we had gas masks because using poisonous
gas wasn't considered a legal in war,
mustard gas and all that shit. Hand to
hand fighting shit in a fucking hole.
Some of the worst conditions ever.
That's where they were sent
all those people up there.
They were all from fucking
New Zealand and Australia.
Not One English man had the fucking
balls to go there in the trenches.
At least this is the way a person
from New Zealand explained it to me.
I might have exaggerated a little bit,
but I'm also trying to get some emails
here. Not One Englishman had the balls,
didn't have the fucking balls.
They were all sitting there with Winston
Churchill holding hands, you know,
having a biscuit. Um, Robert's
here, listen to this ship.
The total number of New Zealand troops
in nurses to serve overseas in 1914 in
1918, um, was 140,
a hundred thousand 444 from a population
of just over a million, 10% of that,
over 10%. A roughly 10% of their
population fought in the war.
42% of the men of military age served
16,697 New Zealanders were killed.
Of course they were.
They sent him right to the front and
41,317 were wounded during the war of 58%
casualty. Right. You know, this
is the kind of shitting with does.
And then I go over there and they
started giving me shit about George Bush.
You know, it's like, why don't you fucking
clear off your register there, Ian,
before you come in and make,
I can't remember the last time.
Some from England gave me
shit about the foreign policy.
I just like fucking pissing them off
because then they keep listening and then
the next time we played the
Leicester Square theater,
hopefully there'll be there.
Then maybe they yell some shit out.
We have a good time. All right.
Question from New Zealand.
Um, I live in Christ
church, New Zealand. Oh Gee,
the Christchurch,
all one word.
I live in Christchurch,
New Zealand, by the way.
I'm going to midnight mass
tonight with Nias Mom.
Uh,
boy with the fucking choir.
He able to in La.
I lodge a those brown eyes bad.
UHM,
Uhm,
two e two years ago we had
an earthquake in New Zealand.
I didn't hear about that. Then
again, I don't pay attention to shit.
Two years ago we had an earthquake,
which wreck the city and killed a couple
hundred people and almost killed me too.
Now for three years I've been going out
with a great girl. She's Nice, smart,
caring, fun to hang out with
and I'm not sick of banging.
Her problem is her cousin got killed in
the earthquake. Oh, sorry to hear that.
And ever since then.
She's been terrified.
The aftershocks have all but stopped now.
But she hasn't recovered every time a
truck buys drives past on the road outside
my house,
she flinches and trembles.
Sometimes she cries randomly.
She won't move away from the city
because all of her family is here and I'm
pretty much at the end of my
rope aside aside from this,
she might be even marriage material
by just can't deal with this anymore.
On the day of the quake, I was within 20
feet of being squashed like a great buy,
a four story building that
fell on the sidewalk. Uh,
I've just been walking on while
she was having lunch in a park.
Okay.
So I can't sympathize with her
meant mental fragility anymore.
It's been too long with no improvement.
Yeah.
Um, I don't even know how the
fuck I expect you to help me.
I guess I just want to complain without
anyone I know in real life calling me an
asshole for it because the perception in
my social circle is that I have to just
deal with it, but I'm not sure I can
do it for another two years anyway.
That's my problem.
Any advice would be appreciated.
Come and do a show in New
Zealand sometimes because
this is a great country for
a tourist and I can't be bothered
going to the states to see you.
And aside from that,
enjoy what might be the longest range.
Go Fuck yourself for the week.
Cheers mate. Take care. Um,
well this meeting as you sound,
I totally relate to that
and you kind of sound like a
little bit of a Waldorf Psycho,
which I also relate to. So
you're probably, you know,
okay.
Despite the fact that building almost
fell on you, which is kind of a stretch,
I consider a building almost fell on you.
Like it starts to fall and
you run out of the way.
Not that I was just there 20 minutes ago.
Yeah.
You wouldn't a thousand other
fucking people. All right. Um,
but anyways, yeah, I totally get
what you, you know, I get it.
I get it.
Two years of every time a truck goes by,
as you start shaking movie doing
that. Yeah. Fucking drive me nuts.
After a while, at some point you've
got to grow up and get over it.
You know,
it's like living with the fucking show.
Wow.
Sitting there with his
eyes are bugged out,
shaken and pain in the fucking
corner. At some point, you know,
you got to grow a Dick. You have,
you asked her to go to that.
Have you asked her to go to therapy?
Maybe you should do that.
That's what Nia suggested when she did.
She did the first podcast that I lost.
Uh, she's not available now.
She was on a little, um,
she suggested that you
ask her to go to therapy.
Just sit down and say,
listen,
I'm concerned with the fact that you
still this traumatized by the earthquake
and I want to help you get
some help and start with that.
And if she doesn't get help and she
keeps shaking and trembling in the corner
and peeing like a little
Yorkshire terrier, um,
I dunno,
Dude.
You either got to break up with her or
you got to lay off the booze because
something's going to, something's
going to, you're going to snap
at some point. She's going to be like,
you're going to be a little drunk.
And you could, you could, you've had a
bad day. You're having a couple. Yeah.
Throwing them down. They'll fucking
shoe. Right. And all of a sudden,
whatever happens, somebody blows
their nose next door and she's
doing that shit.
And you're going to be like,
you're just gonna look at her an imitator
and then,
and that's gonna fucking destroyer.
You're going to do that. Jesus.
That just sounded creepy when I did that.
But it's good. It's kind of happened.
So I tried to get her help her, I would
get out of the fucking relationship.
Yeah. I mean, it's been two fucking years.
It's been two fucking years.
Okay. And, uh, you know,
she's acting like it happened two
weeks ago. Yeah. Two years. That's,
that's plenty of fucking time to get,
I mean,
you never get over losing somebody,
but like,
I still have it be that fucking raw that,
you know,
somebody can't even break wind without
you view breaking down crying is, is uh,
you know,
I mean,
maybe she's that sensitive and if she's
that fucking sensitive and you're not,
I don't know. Sometimes opposites attract,
but I don't think it is in this case.
Uh, that's it. All right. 24 year
old virgin on first date. Hello Bill.
And possibly Neil. Sorry,
she's not here this week.
She was during the first
taping. I'm sorry. Um,
and it should be deduced by the
subject line. I'm a major pussy.
I've had absolutely zero
romantic experiences in my life.
I took some pretty brutal rejections when
I was in high school and have been too
timid to try my luck sense.
It's not like I'm a cowering blubbering
mess when I'm talking to women either.
I just think tend to think why bother.
I know what she's going to say.
It's a loser mentality, which is stupid.
I know. So what do you need my help for,
sir? You know, you're being a
pussy and you know you're, you're,
you're psyching yourself out.
You know what's going on.
Ah, you know what the deal is.
All right, let's keep Rina by now.
There's this girl who's really interested
in me. I'm not used to that feeling,
blah. Come on dude. What? What's,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Okay,
bye. Now these young girl, they
judge me and I'm not used to that.
What are you a fucking cyclops?
You can't believe the kind of
guys that women are interested in.
They're not just about looks,
you know,
they're about senses of humor. Uh, money.
Sorry. I know that they like
other shit. Um, we met in an,
in an English course. She's attractive,
way smarter than me and funny as fuck.
We have a lot in common and she's almost
a single cynical and black card. It is.
I am. She's perfect. She's got a
lot of issues though within the,
within minutes of the
first time we talked,
she started telling me about
how she cuts herself. Oh, Jesus.
And about how often she tries to kill
herself. All right. Right there, dude.
It's over.
Okay.
My Damn Self.
And he goes on to say she's
bipolar and schizophrenia.
All right guys, if you're gonna make up
emails, can you try to do a better job?
Not Make them this fucking over the top.
Okay,
dude, you use deduced in the first fucking
sentence of your email and you're too
fucking dumb to not know to get
away from this. If this is true,
I'll play along whatever.
It's Christmas. I play along.
Let's just act like this is true.
She's bipolar and schizophrenia. Oh,
that's great. She caught herself,
tries to kill herself. She's bipolar.
She's schizophrenia. You
know, I think that, I think
it's all their
bipolar and schizophrenia.
That's like the two piece meal at Kentucky
Fried Chicken with a side of cutting
yourself and it's a go big
gulp of suicide. There you go.
That's what you want to let in your inner
circle. Uh, she's told me that she's,
she has a slew of characters that talk
to her, which she, oh, go fuck yourself.
All right, nice try buddy. Okay,
I'm done with this email. Alright.
Introspective drugs.
Hey bill loved the podcast and I've got
gotten a lot of my friends to listen to
you in the last few months.
I'm a 40 niners fan.
I love hearing patriots fans,
bitch when they get beat.
Well you don't hear that a lot do
you? Huh? Let me ask you a question.
Are you good at catching punts? You
want to play that game sir? Huh?
Haven't won anything in 20 fucking years.
How'd you like that Seattle beat down?
You know what?
Here's my Pete Carroll impression for you.
How many times do you just
see this last night? Whoo,
that sounds too much like ric flair.
I got to get some NFL films,
audio of what he sounds like when he
said when he does that. Anyways, he goes,
I know you hang out with Joe Rogan and
a lot of famous La Comedians and I'm
curious if you ever are willing to
get down with mushrooms or any kind of
psychedelic substance.
Um, get down with it.
Get down. Um, not like today or next week.
Just anytime when the rest of your life,
you seem like the kind of guy
who would be balls out laughing,
making everybody else laugh
with introspective insights.
Oh, there's no doubt.
I would have a great fucking time
if I ever did it, but that's,
that's really what scares me.
You know what I mean?
Like when I listened to people who've
done mushrooms, I listened to it.
It sounds fucking awesome.
It does. But uh, you know,
there's a price that you pay
when you do shit like that. See,
I like being ignorant,
you know what I mean?
Like walking into nature's sober is,
is awesome to me because I don't know
that if I was on mushrooms that I would be
enjoying a tree that much more. The fact
that I never did it. Like, you know,
like the first time you get high
if you shoot up with heroin,
like those guys chase that every fucking
day no matter what they do see that
paid for each game. Wasn't that
unbelievable compared to what, you know,
once you shot up, it's, it's,
it's only so fucking enjoyable.
So
drug scare me because I know that I would
really enjoy them and I've seen what
they've done to a lot of
people's lives. And, um,
and I'm not literally saying you
ended up on the street homeless.
I'm not talking about that extreme thing.
I'm just saying how I've seen a lot of
people waste a lot of time and talent and
potential and all that
type of stuff. But, uh,
I do not question why people
do them at all. You know,
I would love to hallucinate,
you know,
I'd love to talk to a sneaker.
Why wouldn't you talk to everything else
that can talk at this point? I'm on a,
you know, be a new experience. But the
problem is I just feel like I would,
I would love it. And uh, you know,
that's why I don't do it anyways.
There's a lot of comedians
talk about we topical Shit,
but it seems like you have a deep vein
of intelligence that a certain audience
hones in on. Oh, I get it.
I see what you're buttering me up and
you want to do mushrooms with me this,
so this is what you're treating me
like an 18 year old incoming freshmen.
You know he had the most beautiful
girl here. You're not like the others
now dude, I'm, I'm, I'm
not saying I never would,
but like I just, I, I'm not
going, I know myself too.
Well the should I do with
alcoholism that enough,
enough of a fucking side,
you know,
I'm going to be buzzed at night when
I go to church as district. I can't,
I can't show up. And he goes,
mom, no booze on my breath.
I wasn't raised like that.
You know when I tell you, watch that
guy breaks open the wine I l bits,
all bets are off underrated.
A flask
flask at midnight mass.
You know what's the great thing about a
flask is if somebody catches you with it
all yet all you do to get out of
it is you, you, you look at them,
you do that nod and you
give them a little toast
and it's just so awkward.
They have to nod and kind of give you
like a fucking black power fist back to
you. What are they going to do, you know?
Anyways, girlfriend, jealous of dog.
Dearest William. I watched your standup
special, my girlfriend and we loved it.
Oh well thank you very much. Um, anyways,
my girlfriend is jealous of my dog.
The dog is small and I have often
have it laying with me on the couch,
sleeping in bed with us.
Um,
of course I'm cuddling with my girlfriend
at the same time while you cuddle with
a beast, I know it's a little dog,
but still, you know, so you got like,
you've got a little
threesome going on there.
I kind of see why she would be annoyed.
Um,
but she still complains.
Then I'm more affectionate with the dog
and is often mean and abusive to the
dog, pushing her around, calling
her a slut, slash whore, et.
Has this happened to you?
Am I out of my mind or was it strange
for a girl to be jealous of an animal?
All right, dude, here's the thing. Um,
you need to stop sleeping with your dog.
When your girlfriend's there,
you got to know that humans
are higher up than dogs, okay?
Treat your girl with a little more
respect, okay? First off, and secondly,
you need to dump that woman,
okay?
That whole shit.
They're like getting jealous
of the dog is one thing.
Is that jealous of the dog?
She's just upset that you probably
say way more lovey dubby things to the
fucking dog and are way more
affectionate to the fucking dog.
Caressing the dog. Petting it way more
than you are her. So that's normal.
But when she takes it,
the point of the bizarre calling the dog
a slut or a whore and then hitting an
animal, pushing around on any
fucking level, let's that's
a done deal right there.
All right?
If those street lights were there,
I don't know what color
she would come out,
but it wouldn't be the color that I
am. All right? All the American here,
Apple Pie and Chevrolet.
Fuck Chevrolet. I like Fords,
but you know what I'm saying?
That's what you gotta do.
You got to curb your attention.
You're giving to your dog and you
got to dump that woman. That's it.
Anyone who was mean to a fucking animal?
Is there a piece of shit?
And that's the tip of the iceberg.
It's the Bronx tale lock
the door test right there.
You're out. See Ya. All right.
Overrated. Underrated a bill. I love the
podcast and listen to it all the time.
I think there are way too many
overrated sports cliches. For example,
give 110% taking one game at a time,
at the end of the day, et Cetera. Any
halftime interview with any coach.
What do you think, Bill? What's
your opinion on sports cliches?
Are they overrated or underrated?
If so,
what are some of your favorite
slash most annoying ones?
Um, all right. Well this time of year they
always have the classic, I'll tell Ya,
they're the eight and 16. Nobody
wants to play. They got that one.
Um,
they always have that team,
the best team with the shitty
record that nobody wants to play.
MMM.
The,
the, the one that the coach
will say, I'll tell you,
you give me 22 on those guys.
Give me 22 of those guys
and I go on defeated. Uh,
they don't make 'em like that guy. He's
a throwback. That guys is throwback.
The lovely Nia.
Everybody just walked in.
You walked in later and he
went by the whole thing. Um,
what are some of the other ones? Oh,
I, this is the one I hate the most.
I'll tell you. I hate that guy. But
if he played for he had loved them,
they always say that about those
dirty pieces of shit that go and like
deliberately blow somebody's knee out
and in their career. And for the record,
I wouldn't love them if they
played for my team. I wouldn't,
I don't like dirty pieces of Shit,
whether they're wearing the uniform of
the team that I love or that I hate.
I don't like those guys. So, um, I dunno
if that's an overrated, underrated,
but I gave you overrated, underrated,
underrated. Bringing a flask to midnight.
Mass is underrated
and uh, they need to come
over. We only got one. Mike,
come over here for a second.
How was, uh, how'd that Pie look?
That pie looked amazing. It was.
I walked in and I was like, oh, it
was beautiful. You did a great job.
And how manly did I look in that apron?
I don't understand why you won't
allow me to tweet pictures like this.
Well I think cause I get an cause I
get enough shit. Why help him out?
I yeah, I laugh for a solid five minutes
on that one. That was, that was good.
It was great. But that pilot looks
amazing. I can't wait to have it tomorrow.
All right.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to,
I'm going to fucking send out
the picture of the pot. Yeah.
And watch still shit all over that.
They'll shit all over the
edge of [inaudible]. You
already throwing somebody.
They saw me take a shit on it.
Did they know what a gourmet cook you
are though? Have you talked about that?
How you're really your skills
in the kitchen? I've become
quite good. Thank you. That was, that
was those damn near a compliment.
It is a compliment. And you made that,
that prime? No, the braised short ribs,
which was amazing.
Braised short ribs.
He made it a braised short ribs
about this beautiful bottle of wine.
It was very romantic. It was
still, and it was delicious too.
It was like restaurant quality.
Good. Yeah. Overrated
cooking. It's not that hard.
All these fucking jackass is on the food
network and this is blah, blah blah.
This is going to infuse and that's,
it takes a certain amount of
creativity, I think. You know,
to like make something really special.
Anyone can make a by the book recipe,
but you've got to add your own little,
you know,
that's all I'm doing. Udl. You got a
jazz thing. They own. What? Don't ever,
don't ever do that again. No, I don't.
I just follow the recipe word
for fucking word. That's it.
When you get more,
when you get more confident,
you'll be able to improvise a little
bit more. You won't have to do that.
You'll just be like,
I'm making this today.
I seem insecure when I'm in the kitchen
of sitting there wearing a woman's
fucking apron.
You got you. You, you're wearing my
friend. Yeah. That your mom gave me.
So it was kinda like, well, either way
I laughed. Yes, she did. All
right, well, merry Christmas,
Nia and Chris. Merry
Christmas. Happy Hanukkah.
Happy Kwanza and Christmas everybody.
Everybody.
And thank you everybody that sheer,
everybody coming out to my shows.
Everybody who's listened, anybody who
is advertised on this pod pod class,
podcast.
God bless Ya.
Go fuck yourselves.
We got one more Monday left in this year.
I hope you guys have good time. Dona.
And I know there's gonna be some Douche
bags at Christmas and in law or it's
just somebody you don't fucking
like and uh, just whatever. Don't,
don't engage for the sake of your mom,
your dad, or just everybody or the,
even the person you're with. Just don't
get involved in it. All right? And just,
I dunno, I dunno. Tam,
go stand under the street light to see
what color they are. All right. That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.